damit der hollywood wasser hat vorjahr
nur zwölf minuten
murat ernsthaft herzlich willkommen
monats fünf minuten und zwar heute
machen was ganz cool ist was ganz
einfach ist die einfachste rezept sind
meiner meinung nach die besten wir
machen wir kochen auf geringem
bildungsniveau
dafür hab ich ihn eingeladen der so
intelligent ist wie drei meter feldweg
ihr kennt ihn in petrol auf 35 im juni
zusammen machen ein ganz einfaches
rezept mit zutaten ja nicht jeder zu
hause hat oder die meisten hier zu hause
zum beispiel reis hat immer jemand jeder
zu hause gar reisen nudeln hast auch
zuhause reis und nudeln hat der bühne
auch immer in der psychiatrie in seinem
schrank brett stehen ansonsten aber so
ansonsten haben wir hier machen wir
nicht was wir machen kinder bin da ja
wir machen sowas wie chinesische
reispfanne was ehrlich es ja wir haben
leider kann ich die nächsten dabei aber
wir haben ja bereits vorbei genau auf
jeden fall machen wir irgendwas mit
fleisch und mit reis und mit gemüse ich
habe das natürlich tagelang ausgedacht
in dem video zusammen was wir machen
werden und dann ist man auch die fünf
zutaten kommen richtig daneben jetzt
anfangen mit den zutaten also ganz
einfach wir haben hier 200 gramm reis
dann haben wir 300 gramm fleisch ja ihr
könnt aber auch normale sie könnten
nicht nehmen schweizer geht nicht es
geht nur fleisch
nein geht auch nicht warum nicht was
nicht geht auf die umwelt geht so auf
jeden fall dann haben wir hier eine
paprika dann haben wir frischen
knoblauch der braucht nur zwei zehen
naja dann haben wir hier noch 22
schonend getrocknet dann haben wir hier
noch ja dann haben wir noch zuckererbsen
zu bewerten sind
das gewusst hat es zugelassen sind dort
mehr bohnen ich habe es gelesen haben
nach versuche ganz stark dann haben wir
hier
frühlingszwiebeln und zwar vier stück
dessen frühlingszwiebeln übrigens dann
nehmen wir mal einkaufen geht es
frühlingszwiebeln sehen so aus dann
haben wir vier esslöffel olivenöl
normalerweise wenn etwa scharf anbraten
wie das fleisch nachher mit mir in
erdnussöl wer es den hohen rauch punkt
hat man kann es richtig heiß erhitzen
über 52 grad bei erdöl österreich trat
er wirklich aufnehmen bei olivenöl hier
ist nichts wildes nebenraum punktgenau
das verbrennt ist mir aber egal welchen
erdöl gefunden habe erdnussöl gefunden
habe habe ich olivenöl genommen da haben
wir hier gemüsebrühe der bauausschuss
haben einfach die gemüsebrühe frau
genommen die macht immer selber dann
haben wir es mit wasser einfach
verdünnten gemüsebrühe draus gemacht
haben angesetzt sind ja richtig schlau
ja du hast doch selber noch schlauer ja
genau
auf jeden fall ja das haben wir die
zutaten findet er alle aufs eis -
blog.de
wenn jetzt nicht mitgekommen seien werde
zu schnell war oder zu hoch mit wie zum
beispiel jetzt will man fange mit dem
gemüse zu schneiden oder datum alles auf
die seite genau das gemüse haben wir
schon gemacht und genau das geben wir
schon gewaschen danke die hilfe jetzt
halt noch mal wie man die zuckererbsen
ja und zwar nicht genau wir zeigen euch
ein hack wie man zu geerbt und putzt und
zwar zuckererbsen putzen geht ganz
einfach
und zwar um einfach hier vorne und
hinten abschneiden und harrt der dinge
ein faden hat kein faden
die erbsen selben zeit auch immer das
macht ja macht man muss sagen wo sie
parken
die haben vielleicht gefressen haben
wir haben patienten mit gestörter
irgendjemand der faden das hat mir hier
der faden sich gestellt muss ich ehrlich
sagen das sieht ja und dann nachher sagt
selber denn da hat es sinn hast du da
drin gelassen
auf jeden fall jetzt haben wir die
erbsen hatten geputzt jetzt kann man
eigentlich die frühlingszwiebeln
schneiden
diese steigen kannst du machen wir das
so ausgemacht hat nein ist das nicht
machen das war der erste fehler wie kann
man nur so was machen und zwar das ist
ein japanisches maß messe ja und zwar
dann machst du das japanisch damals
messer ist nun das messer und zwar warum
weiß ich eigentlich warum es damals
besser ist es das messer und dass somit
das ist ja nett aus dem us-kongress
kommt aus der maske aus syrien
so jetzt nur schneiden genau und zwar
das besondere an dem an einem
gemüsemesser ist dass es keine gerade
linie hat sondern einen leichten wellen
das heißt ganz so so so so machen
ja ja wie beim chinesen ma ka zeigt man
hier
okay das ja ich bin gut oder kennst du
eigentlich peter hier geht es in einer
von uns am stammtisch
er ist letzte woche gestorben
dass man beim frühlingssingen
leidenschaft
schneider ja ach diese eingeschlafen so
wie du jetzt gemacht auf jeden fall
wollte ich sagen ich hab's vergessen
das tolle ist beim energie schneidet
brauchst du keine harmonischen aufnahme
wir machen wenn es so langsam ist machst
du bist du fertig ist ist das ding schon
wieder vergangen mit weicher des
ausgedruckten ja ausgetrocknet
daran kann man da einblenden zwei
stunden später in der zwischenzeit so
lang wie nie ist es ruhig die paprika
aushöhlen und zwar mit einem messer
humax und zwar haben wir dieses
japanische aus was sagen also und zwar
ganz einfach paprika schneiden geht
einfach und es gab es das talent angeht
gehört ja erstmal den strunk ausholen
wenn man nochmal rheinbrücke das haben
reingedrückt das land tue ich ihn
auseinander schneiden
jetzt haben wir das ding ausgehöhlt und
jetzt durch das waschen das hier hast
geschnitten kinder kümmern dass als
nächstes schneiden und zwar in streifen
wie aber kleiner
ja bitte immer ein bis zwei stunden
später nicht manchmal ist das problem
ich glaube im rat finden und verzögere
sich nur wegen dir du stellst nur der
geplanten 80 großes machen da ist doch
du okay das muss eigentlich raus kommen
schon den krieg mitgemacht doch mit dir
gleich warum später sozusagen auch so
lange wie nie so lagen die gründe der
schneide steigt das fleisch und zwar in
streifen beim fleisch ist wirklich egal
was ja was nimmt wir haben es viele
genommen beim felix fall schon mal viele
geschmäcker nicht immer ist aber etwas
teurer
ihr könnt auch ganz normales höchst
fleisch nehmen oder auch vom hals oder
irgendwas schweinegülle könnte nicht
nehmen ihr könnt mir um welches sich
nehmen darf man auf jeden fall nun nicht
nicht daran dachten es nicht weiß ich ja
wir sind auch bei mir zu hause sony auf
jeden fall tun wir das ding auch
schneiden und zwar da hole ich ein
anderes messer also okay ich habe mir
was anderes überlegt gerade beim römer
noch nichts was eingefallen und zwar ich
mache schon mal der avl reise
hahaha denn es gibt zwei methoden in
reis zu machen uns bald mit wasser oder
mit mit quellwasser kinder mit
streifenwagen quer reisezeit ganz ganz
einfach und zwar das quält einfach auf
und zwar so wie zum beispiel genau ist
auch was genau ist auch menschliche
quellen reis rauskommt als ein dutzend
und jetzt nehmen wir nicht zu vergessen
ist mir dann eingefangen
juni ich habe vergessen darf nicht ganz
kurz der chefkoch braucht eine schürze
schokolade machen möchte man sagen kann
du glaubst gar nicht ich glaube daran
sagt ein stück schokolade mir ein glaubt
mir trau mich einfach wieder vertrauen
mir es gibt noch einen coolen geschmack
jetzt machen wir einen kreis und zwar
quer ist es ganz ganz einfach zu machen
das würden auch die dummies verstehen
also sogar die queen hat es verstanden
das ist ein bäcker reis einbrecher
reißen ungefähr 200 gramm oder 100
milliliter
kommt drauf an was ein faktor in dem
traktor schlimmer 9,7 kommt doch waren
wir auf der erde und auf dem mond zeit
hat aber den wasserspiegel zu tun auf
jeden fall 200 gramm hast du bist
gelesen das konto nicht von dir doch du
hast du absolut 200 tue ich einfach rein
und zwar nehme man was falsch
und zwar ein becher reis und zweieinhalb
becher wasser erst das wasser rein
dann tut mir ein bisschen würze nicht
würzen salzen meine seite sagt aber auch
die zuhörer ein 20
salzen okay so dieses salz bisschen viel
salz reingemacht
es ist schlimm so hast du probleme im
cholesterinspiegel nicht okay jetzt
gleich schon so dann immer diesen reiss
hier aber erst muss wasser aufkochen und
zwar erwarten dieses wasser heiß wird
zumindest wasser heiß ist dann machen
wir nehmen auch nicht wir warten nicht
wisse was reißen wir uns gleich rein und
zwar heißt es kreis wenn man das wasser
rein machte sich heiß und der tut man
den reis rein und dann lässt das
aufquellen und dann machen wir halt
wieder aus und dann ist reis fertig
manchen oder saure teil dieser quelle
ist ja weil ihr habitat beim mini der
warsteiner 18 jahren schon weg wollen
jetzt den reis rein und warten bis es
auf kocht und jetzt aufgekocht ist
thomas einfach ich dass man einmal
schwenken wir haben jetzt geschwenkt
beispiel franck weiß kein mensch auf
dieser welt warum jetzt schwimmt gast
wenn es hammer professionell aussehen
würde auf jeden fall wenig wilder stier
steht mit schokolade ist nicht
geschnitten
glaub mir du wirst nachher sagen boah
was für eine geniale schokolade in der
zwischenzeit nehmen wir das fleisch und
das gleicht das ufer schneiden und zwar
fleisch in scheiben schneiden
ich habe eine tolle idee bringen wir
nehmen uns einfach das genau
ich habe dir vor vergessen was zu sagen
und zwar guck mal du hast mit dem messer
mit der schneide klinge geht es über
spread gezogen das darf nicht okay immer
mit dem rücken dem messerrücken mal vor
alles daran so auf jeden fall jetzt nur
noch ein bisschen die schokolade und
zwar die schokolade skater murat ist
macht sagt zack zack zack zack zack
wer braucht schon städten händler das
ist gesehen und dann immer dieses
fleisch und normalerweise macht man das
nicht dass man fleisch auf gemüsebett
schneidet okay jetzt das war jetzt ein
zweiter fehler heute wenig beim dritten
bis daraus moment wer hat das fleisch
vertraut geworden ich hatte richtig
wieder hingeflogen auf jeden fall macht
man jetzt so ist aber nicht schlimm aber
gemüse erst mühsam und dann fleisch
andersrum ich blöd jetzt schneiden wir
es in scheiben streichen streifen
ich nehme jetzt hier normalerweise
nehmen würde ich ein normales kochmesser
nehmen aber ich weiß nicht wo es ist
sieht das aus wie döner
das ist das schöne dünne scheiben
schneiden beim reis kreistag welt schon
auf der quinta da guckt was mach ich den
deckel drauf ja und zwar den hier ja wir
schalten runter mach es einfach wenn du
schon mal heiß gemacht hat hat schon mal
reist in dein leben gemacht
ok dann nochmal hier nochmal das stück
und schneiden das auch noch macht so
siehst du das wie schnell es geht wie
nie ich bin wie eine maschine gelöst und
schöne scheiben geschnitten wird es noch
kleiner stein streife entschuldigung des
schneidens nochmaligen streifen
das ist so bitter weil dick ist nie gut
geht es sicher auch schon okay so jetzt
kann man das fleisch und die schokolade
und jetzt tun wir folgendes machen und
zwar vieles was ganz ganz besonderes es
ist sehr sehr schnell durch und wir
möchten ja nicht so richtig gummi in
fleisch haben das weiß ganz kurz
anbraten dann raus aus der pfanne oder
genauer scharf angreifen heiß und
scharfes gleiche nein dann eben nicht
folgendes jetzt sogar kurz die eisenbahn
nehmen und zwar über tom bist du kurz
dabei und zwar beim anbraten ist immer
ich das lied ist mal wenn ich gleich
irgendwas an gerade scharf anbraten
jemand der eisenbahn es ist echt des
cousins es gibt wirklich
warum machen wir das weil reisen plane
ganz heiß wird und zwar ganz schnell
wird ja und dann neben und dann zwar
gerne hier hoch langsam erhitzen und
zwar wirklich langsam hoch weil weil
sonst die pfanne sich musikalisch und zu
schnell hoch geheizt wird dann künftig
verbieten deswegen ganz kurz langsam an
auf stufe 2 3 und dann hoch auf 6 japan
brachen bei all oder aluminium sowie
fragen wenn ich hab nur wenig anfangen
ok so haben wir verstehen jetzt immer
olivenöl
normalerweise nimmt man ab jetzt
gefunden wer hat so was einen schon zu
hause sterben ist zu hause eine samstag
ist hast du zu hause sondern nur halb
voll
ohne panne wirklich niemals leer
erhitzen sich auch ganz ganz wichtig
weißt du warum gehen
warum man das öl brenner kann man so alt
wird
ehrlich jetzt fast money filmen öl brent
neid das sieht man das programm auf
jeden fall nehmen wir jetzt das fleisch
das kann man ja schlecht wegen langsamer
der reichstag weltgipfel zum burn einmal
angerührt ja wo ich mal hinten links
kein holz oder sowas nein wir haben kein
holz doch du hast ein holzkopf jetzt
kümmern kurzer tritt maria und zwar kurz
reinhold in der cdu ist genug zeit läuft
und jetzt tun wir das fleisch gerade
rein
aua aua kann man hier in länder mit
blauen scheiben schneiden ja und gut
solange eine klage auch in scheiben
schneiden und jetzt kurz anbraten
rickling die allzu lang umso kleiner das
fleisch geschnitten hat um so wie er
unser kürze müsst ihr anbraten jetzt
natürlich noch ein bisschen würze
fleisch salz und pfeffer nach belieben
die crew auch jetzt nicht hier rein
machen müssen auch egal
dann ist gerade brennt lichterloh es ist
schon ganz schön die schokolade den
fehler was jetzt kriegen natürlich
gemacht hat ich fleisch immer mit
kleinen portionen nur ein bisschen
weniger rein und dann noch tut sich was
heimat nicht alles auf einmal weil sonst
zieht sofort das wasser ohne hast
vielleicht ein bisschen weg das heißt
immer ein bisschen fleisch und danach
noch mal so ich sag's ihnen werden
schwerer gemacht weil du so dass für die
so ist das verdikt es reicht schon viele
wirklich nicht zu sehr
jetzt auch ein bisschen soße sagt so
jetzt sind es 20 rein und lassen die
kampagne grad so und jetzt tut man das
gemüse mit rein
der granit und inzwischen seien unsere
zwei getrockneten sieges noch schneiden
von atom chips mit 4 1
jetzt kann man einfach das gemüse rein
[Musik]
ist das erst mal ganz kurz das gemüse
anbraten andünsten und dann nachher im
nächsten schritt zum ablöschen nochmal
gemüsebrühe rein machen kannst du das
kannst du mir gratis gegeben
machen sie können es dann nach berlin
jetzt mal ein bisschen knoblauch
reinmachen
der gegner hat jetzt angekündigt ist
jetzt grade anbraten will ich krieg
scharf
das kann man sich richtig richtig gut
das kann man natürlich richtig in der
bobbahn gemacht wir haben es leider
keinen bock hier und jetzt versuchen
irgendwie so zu halten wie die eisenbahn
das richtig genial
jetzt wird der krimi das ganze noch
natürlich würzen war ich kurz ein
bisschen pfeffer ein bisschen salz und
jetzt noch ein stück schokolade die
anflüge bringen genau nach belieben
jetzt die angesetzte gemüsebrühe drauf
das coole ich jetzt auch ein langer clip
jetzt kann man auch ein bisschen so
macht es den chinesen bei uns auch immer
wahnsinn jetzt ist es einfach ein
bisschen auftauchen lassen
das gibt einen richtig tollen geschmack
jetzt probiert er es weiß ist noch ein
bisschen
jetzt tut das richtig bisschen aufpassen
ein bisschen reduzieren noch ein
bisschen einfach jetzt purzeln lassen
bis das wasser komplett wirklich
verdunstet ist und nachts immer noch
kurz mit rein
den reis servieren oder ist man schon
fertig und das ding rezept hat
normalerweise und wenn du schnell genug
gewesen herrscht wirklich aller
höchstens fünf minuten gedauert oder die
sechs minuten wenn ich einen menschen
manchmal ein opferlamm mannschaft schon
bei der stadt oder bearbeiten etwa der
staat so langsam wenig gemüse natürlich
knackig haben möchte ist will ich nur
ganz ganz ganz kurz kann also wie man
ihm einen chinesen auch ganz ganz kurz
kam
wir möchten gemüse ein bisschen weich
haben weil ich bin ich auch nicht mehr
die jüngste und seiner kauleiste das ist
auch essen kann knacke werken problem
weniger thomas kahlisch marie kritisch
preisen ok auf jeden fall deswegen lass
mich und was wir machen und zwar ich
habe gerade noch im auto noch so ja
sowieso gefunden und schluckt mehr
kümmern müssen rein machen sei damit
nicht
seid wirklich offen für neues in
saarbrücken werden sie jetzt
wahrscheinlich noch magie reim machen
sie machen so wieso habe ich einen
ellenbogen im gesicht wenn man schätze
mal so ein ellbogencheck abtrieb zu
klein
so kann ich nix dafür sind ellbogen im
gesicht so auf jeden fall machen jetzt
noch folgendes noch aber das nur ganz
kurz und zwar jemandem auf gleich mit
dem ganzen sucht noch das geht jetzt
auch mit rein und dann ist unsere nennt
sie das rezept ich überhaupt nicht
chinesisch nur wenig soja reingemacht
habe okay so auf jeden fall haben wir
unsere gemüse reis panne genau dieses
gemüse reis 30 inzwischen auch gekommen
richtig aufgefallen wie der grünen der
stadt jetzt immer einfach den reis der
schon aufgequollen sowie der gummi jetzt
immer und ich tue jetzt einfach ab
geht's noch stadt hemer kurz gedacht
okay so jetzt machen wir folgendes jetzt
haben wir ein teller
jetzt nehmen wir hier nämlich gerade
hier ich habe das meiner frau gesehen ja
erst mal gemacht
[Musik]
was für eine blöde idee die wüste
geschickt
ja erstmal uns einfach anders dann nimmt
man einmal denn die hat mir tolle idee
und zwar muss so sei der falsche weg ist
auch wieder das auch und zwar zack und
zwar immer noch hier was anrichten
lassen
so habe nur was zu dekorieren irgendwie
das blöd aus nein
jetzt findet sie toll aus so noch ein
bisschen zu viel drüber
wir würden jetzt gern ausprobieren
lassen ganz einfach weil das sehr mag
ist noch relativ jung der magen der held
noch einiges aus sie haben auch kurz
kommt ist angespannt doch vielleicht nur
ein cisco bereich wenn es nicht über was
jetzt
[Applaus]
foto konsistenz her ja durch gerade
kollege gäste das war gerade ein euro 20
das eine stück ja auf jeden fall aus
gemüse probieren mit na ja auch das
gemüse ja natürlich schauen auch veganer
zug er probiert auch das gemüse ja ich
glaub zwar noch nicht aber ja ich hoffe
trinkt gewesen sagt dann ist ein
genetischer die sich uns war ist
folgendes reist auch schokolade drin
märkte das merkst du gar nicht so
einfach und schnell gemacht wir wirklich
an schafft es vielleicht die hälfte
nimmt oder sowas und auch nur ganz ganz
kurz anbraten dann ist sie wieder auch
kostengünstig würde ich sagen ihr könnt
auch ein anderes fleisch nehmen ihr
könnt auch zum beispiel punkte nehmen
oder sowas schreiben kreis war nein das
kann nicht machen aber es ist da geht
das ding kaputt aber richtig gut
sie habe halt das gemüse gefüllt
ehrliches gemüse es ist jetzt echt
begeistert ist im laufen ist ohne spaß
das ist echt unter uns okay zeit voll
ehrlich jetzt kommen doch etwas mit
meiner meinung mein vater macht auch
allgemein gesagt ja ich habe schon
probieren nicht deshalb danke ich ja nur
probieren ja nicht so ist dann gesagt
essen sollte ein cooles gezeigt wie
gemacht das nachkochen auf geringem
bildungsniveau mit gummi und mir sein
ich bin sein betreuer und stieß das auf
jeden fall war ja auf jeden fall ganz
toll da hab ich noch ein oder zwei ossis
ihm gefällt und ich bin nicht voll
gemacht und wollte übrigens auch seine
eigenen neuen facebook seite auf hat
mein institut seite uns war
juni können sie aufarbeiten eigenen
kanal
doch wirklich erfreut ist eigentlich
machen geht hat sie ihm klarmachen
doch nicht nur alles solle nicht
kennenlernen
das macht
[Musik]